[Music]
thank you for coming along to our talk
on using AI to transform fleet
operations
my name is Mubeen dim and I work in a
Hitachi consulting within the strategy
and innovation team hi Mandy Lamont I
working over at digital transformation
practice in the UK so today we're here
to talk to you about Hitachi's
predictive maintenance platform for
fleet operations just to give you a bit
of an overview of how this session is
going to be structured it's gonna be
similar to everywhere you've been
already we're gonna essentially tell you
why we've done what we've done over the
past three or four months so giving you
some information around the industry
issues we're trying to tackle from the
fleet open up from from a fleet
management perspective we're gonna spend
some time showing you how we've done
what we've done by taking you through
the architecture and taking you through
some of those challenges and design
decisions we've made and then we're
gonna show you because I think that's
the most important part right you want
to see what we've done and we'll give
you a demonstration of how we've applied
this with one of our clients as well the
key thing I think all of you are
probably wondering is why do we have
Lego and this let's address that
elephant in the room
you've probably walked around the
conference rooms and seen the Lego at
the booth and I think more people have
been fascinated by the Lego than
anything else essentially it's a whole
lot easier to bring one of those from
the UK than bringing an actual vehicle
so we've got this to support one of our
use cases around a are guided
inspections and we'll give you a lot
more information about that as we go
through this session if we could hold
all questions until the end as well will
allocate some time for that but if we
don't get around to you because we run
out of time please swing by the booth
ask for Meredith she'll be able to help
you out there as well thank you it's
perfect I think we've talked about this
but essentially our aims are to show you
what we've done explain why we've done
it but also show you where we're going
next and just to give you all a bit of
context and information about Hitachi so
you've all probably heard of us because
we touch pretty much all industries from
an industrial perspective to it
nology perspective we are a global
technology leader founded over 100 years
ago and a global industrial powerhouse
with long-term stability and deep
resources Hitachi has deep experience in
the industrials and manufacturing space
and especially within the kind of
vehicles and fleet management space so
there's some interesting information out
there I won't talk about all of it but
over 70% of vehicles have at least one
Hitachi component and Hitachi
manufactures components that amount to
up to 45% of the component building
materials you'll have in a vehicle so we
have deep deep experience in the
manufacturing space there but we also as
Hitachi have a lot of experience in the
ownership and operation of large fleet
operations as well so that's spanning
from the automotive to the trucking to
the heavy asset so your your earth
moving materials as well and along those
lines attaches also got deep experience
around IRT AI and we're bringing
together those with our use of Google as
our platform for bringing our industrial
experience and heritage to the industry
to help our clients within the industry
innovate and move forward we also are a
combination of 800-plus subsidiary
companies and that's how you've probably
seen a lot of Hitachi touch in your
world so what are we here for today so
today we're here to talk about fleet
management and how predictive
maintenance can support fleet management
activities fleet optimization activities
specifically fleet management solutions
need to evolve they need to move from
where they are currently fleet
management solutions are often reactive
visualizations of the information that
you have available to yourselves
reactive in terms of maintenance but
also reactive in terms of any kind of
optimization activities as well today
flee or flee organizations essentially
have to compete with a number of
disrupting factors such as startups
other entrants into the market
rising fuel prices and
lexie mission-based regulations that's
forcing them to focus on efficiencies
and within that maintenance costs for
fleets account for 15 to 20 percent of
your fleets total costs so a prime area
for optimization and a prime area for AI
and IOT based solutions to help reduce
that cost digital technologies are
changing most industries in all areas
and this is somewhere where there's a
great opportunity to provide
efficiencies and cost savings just to
give you all a bit of contextual
background information there are a
number of fleet maintenance optimization
challenges that need to be addressed
so fleet managers often lack the
pertinent asset condition data they may
have data but a lot of the data that
gets collected across fleets is
cluttered by individuals as opposed to
necessarily being streamed back from the
vehicles themselves in all instances
there's excessive operational
maintenance cost so a majority of
organizations from a maintenance
perspective do periodic or cyclical
maintenance where essentially you are
maintaining the asset on a time-based
process to essentially reduce the risk
associated with that asset failing at
any point in time that's due to a lack
of available asset condition data and a
limited understanding of the
relationships between the assay failure
event and the data that you can get from
those assets beforehand assets are
becoming a whole lot more complex as
well so fleet operators are having to
manage at larger scales with more
complex assets and that brings with it
its own nightmares as well and there's
also the challenge around knowing when
to maintain your assets and when to
replace your assets so for example
end-of-life for assets is calculated by
organizations usually on a time basis we
can bring additional data in to help
those types of organizations retire
those assets and replace those assets
when they need to
just because a certain time is elapsed
so this is the maturing process the move
to predictive maintenance doesn't happen
overnight we're on this trend moving
from data reporting through to
descriptive analytics and dashboards to
help people understand their assets and
through the use of data and bringing in
data you're able to move to the
predictive world before we get to the
prescriptive world where you're doing
things because you feel they're going to
fail or you're doing things before you
need to do it
moving to predictive maintenance is
expected to save 10 to 20 percent over
preventative maintenance practices and
we'll break that down a little bit as we
talk through this conversation and why
now the big question is has this not
been possible previously why are we able
to do this at this point technology
convergence is a key reason we're able
to essentially bring a number of
different data sets together from both
edge devices within vehicles within
assets as well as streaming data from
other data sources so we're talking
about the Met we're talking about
condition data and all those pieces
enabled by cloud computing and big data
toolkit so they really allow us to
stream and store vast amount of data
efficiently economically and securely
providing monitoring capabilities and
the ability to make interventions before
issues occur they are machine learnings
could be trained against these large
data sets at comparatively low cost
compared to in the past and advanced
visualizations through the use of
augmented reality and also automated
dashboarding and those elements can help
surface the information to the right
individuals at the right time so that
they can make those interventions as
needed and the big question we have to
ask is well why do you do these things
why do you go through the pain of
understanding and working through those
data elements and it's all about
delivering value for the organization's
so fleet operations aren't essentially
anticipated to
juice costs by moving to predictive
maintenance improve efficiency so I'll
give you a few examples if we look at
maintenance as it stands at the moment
we talked about it being done on a
cyclical basis if you maintain assets
when they need to be maintained as
opposed to for the sake of it you reduce
the downtime for those assets so for
example you don't need to take vehicles
out of service to go and do maintenance
against those assets you therefore make
those assets available and you can
improve your revenues against those at
that point you're reducing your
operational cost you're not having
individuals having to go and service
assets that do not need to be done and
you also are able to manage your capex
and essentially focus and work on those
assets that need the work when they need
the work so I've given you a bit of
context and bit of information around
wifely organisations need to consider
predictive maintenance need to
understand their assets better and
that's understood and that's a key
driver across the industry however there
are technological challenges associated
with this in terms of streaming back
fleet data so a lot of the data that you
pull off the vehicles for example are
unstructured or the data sources that
available come through a time series
data with varying structures and schemas
IOT data itself isn't going to help you
generate insight insight comes together
from a combination of additional
contextual data sources so knowing the
actual event a vet events that were
occurring at that point in time climate
temperature terrain where you were with
that vehicle and also within the work
we've done we've identified that you
need SME input you need the knowledge
and information from those SMEs that are
working in that space to help you focus
on the right use cases you can bring
back data for many sources but unless
it's actually serving a purpose and
working for the use case to help the
organization deliver value it's not
going to be worthwhile
perfect so I'll give you a bit of an
overview here around what we have
created and why we've created it
so essentially Hitachi is used GCP
technologies to deliver a predictive
maintenance fleet operational solution
which overcomes some of the challenges I
talked about we do two things
predominantly and we'll go into a lot of
detail around this from a actual feature
perspective and functionality
perspective but just as a high-level
overview at this point we've created
data dashboards for maintenance planners
that look at the data that we pull out
of those vehicles compared to contextual
data sources and they look at the full
information that we've already created
and the AI models we have created to
predict fault events and they surface
the right recommendations to that
maintenance planner at the right time so
they know where and when they need to
maintain assets comparing that against
the alerts that are also coming back
from the vehicle so it can be
dynamically updated throughout their
kind of planning process but also
looking at the normal maintenance
schedules as well for those assets that
are not quite ready for this what we've
also done is working with our client
around the maintenance and inspection
space as well as we help them identify
where they need to work on their assets
and we're using an AR guided inspection
application to help their largely mobile
workforce understand the steps they need
to take to complete that inspection
against that vehicle so our client has a
large mobile workforce but they also
have a large number of contractors that
they use as well and the use of an AR
guarded application has been super
useful to helping those contractor
workforce individuals understand what
they need to do and where they need to
do it we'll give you a demonstration of
that as well so that is using the AR
components of Android but also using
Google glass as well so in terms of
giving you the overview of what we've
done and how we've done I'll touch on
the concept so our solution looks
the end-to-end using GCP all the way
from data ingestion from either the obd
terminal that we have in the vehicle or
additional sensors that we instill in
that vehicle and Andy will take us
through in a white little while the
Google DCP components we use from an
architecture perspective and why we use
those we bring through the data and both
stream of backs depending on the use
case it's all around what we need to
show when we need to show it and then
using Google's capabilities from an AI
perspective using auto ml ml we
essentially are doing the analysis
against that data set to identify those
fault events and we're visualizing all
of that information through assisted
reality and data dashboards using Google
Data studio and also the mobile and
glass application as I've talked about
so just to give you an understanding of
why we're doing what we're doing and how
we got to where we are today within
Europe a Hitachi
own and operate a number of rail trains
and we provide those trains to
organisations but also they do the
maintenance services against those
vehicles as well as it actually were
creating those trains they were looking
at what data we would need to pull back
from those vehicles and structuring the
development of those and also the
development of the data capture elements
on those vehicle on those trains to
bring back that information so we could
do things like asset monitoring and and
asset optimization that has evolved as
we've moved on to the GCP suite that's
where we're looking now with our fleet
clients which will show the demo for to
do predictive maintenance using GCP so
bringing in all of that information is
great and visualizing is great but we
are taking that next step forward
bringing in contextual data sources and
identifying those types of failure
events that require intervention so big
question is why ai why now and the move
from kind of descriptive analytics to
predictive analytics is driven by a
maturity in AI technology
so this won't be new to a lot of you in
the room but as businesses are evolving
faster than ever
data has to keep up and deliver the
insights for those individuals within
the organization's and bring that data
to the frontlines to help them make the
decisions as and when they're needed and
capitalizing on data is not new how
people have been doing it throughout
time the difference now is that this
evolution of compute and this evolution
of scale and speed and diversity in the
types of models that are available and
the type of Big Data technologies that
are available through Google Cloud from
a capture all the way to a storage
processing and insights perspective are
pretty much ready at this point in time
to help deliver those insights it's not
about big or small data it doesn't
matter how small the dataset is it's
about how you leverage it with the
insight from the industry for the right
use cases to deliver value to those
individuals as well and this is all
about the move from understanding or
hindsight through to insight so how do
you get insight available within your
organization to know where you need to
work and the overall overarching aim is
to getting to foresight where you're
able to go and do things before they
occur we've all see Minority Report
right and just to touch on this as we're
talking through this Hitachi has deep
experience with in the maintenance world
Hitachi has deep experience with in the
IOT world as well so we are able to
leverage not just the AR components of
Google we're also able to leverage the
experience that Hitachi has across the
maintenance space from a disparate
descriptive analytics space to
predictive and also some of the newer
things around prescriptive analytics as
well so for example Itachi has a our
solution cause that we were able to
containerize and bring into the Google
environment to do certain things such as
operations risk or so driver behavior
and we've used some of that insight not
necessarily to detect those faults but
to support that data set that we
using for the brakes example which I'll
take you through later today and also
there's really important things there
around remaining useful life
estimation and fall predictions around
other use cases that we haven't
necessarily touched on in this space but
the purpose of me showing this and
explaining this is to say we have great
experience in this space and we're able
to bring those with whatever use cases
people are looking to work on as well
and all of this is in the pursuit of
total operation optimization and
automation so it's about moving from the
hindsight world to insight and also to
the optimization space where AI is not
only helping you understand what you
need to do but orchestrating and run it
running that for you as an end-to-end
system we're not quite there but that's
where everybody should be fair walking
towards as well so I'll stop there for
one second just do a quick time check
with Andy how we doing okay fine yeah
I'll let you know that I'm I get told
that I like to talk a lot so just have
to use Andy to keep me honest I'm here
to throw him off the stage okay perfect
so before we actually get in and start
showing you a bit about the architecture
I'll describe some of the features of
what we've been doing and when we do the
demo I'll explain some of those pieces
as well so our fleet operations platform
does the normal condition monitoring
element so you bring through the data
you show some of the basic elements like
Mars driven where the assets are and
those elements we also do advanced
failure prediction so we have two use
cases we're talking about today one
around failure for air conditioning
units on fleet vehicles and one around
failure prediction for the brake pad or
brake elements of the vehicles as well
we also have anomaly detection models
where we look at peak performance versus
normal performance we bring in the
intelligent driver score elements that
we talked about and we surface all of
this to our end user being the
maintenance planner through prioritized
maintenance dashboards where we offset
the real-time predictive recommendations
against some of the cyclical work that's
been going on as
and we also surfaced that information
through mobile and glass applications to
the engineers who are out there doing
the inspections and completing that work
perfect I now hand over to Andy yeah
thank you very much
he'll give you an overview of some of
the architecture components about what
we've been working on cool I so yeah
we've obviously talked about the fact
that the end-to-end capability we
looking to use GCP for this we've built
the platform with a number of the
components so again I'm just maybe just
give you a bit of an insight into the
high level platform predominantly this
is best around Google's blueprint for
IOT you probably see lots of diagrams in
this area this is very summarized I
think the important aspect in all of
this is not you know this architecture
doesn't necessarily for every use case
we have to bring in and use different
components of the GCP family to address
some of the challenges so again
depending on the speed that you need to
consume the data whether you're looking
at these things in real time whether you
want to do things in batch you may end
up using different products this is just
a I guess the common ones you would tend
to use in such a solution from our point
of view I guess more recently cloud a
cloud IOT core is something that we've
introduced some of our clients
historically wouldn't have used this
they would have used direct connections
or stored the information centrally but
now with IOT core we can connect
directly to these devices and again it's
part of the platform we've we've proven
some of that technology out so this this
is here - I guess predominantly we want
- this is not just for the sensor data
I think asthma beans mentioned
previously there's lots of other
information you want to bring into the
platform to actually enhance the the
prediction models and again different
clients I've got different volumes of
information so I think back to one of
the other slides you know from a rails
perspective if they have a lot more days
of potential than what you maybe have on
the car so you've obviously the platform
you can scale out you Nabal to process
it you're able to
use the power of the of the GCP based on
the input the data that's coming into
the solution I think again what we've
touched on previously there's lots of
talk about containerization and again
coming back to the algorithms that are
the solution cause it actually likes the
colon that we've got we we can obviously
bring those into the platform so again
we don't always have to use
GCP products we can introduce our own
technologies and things that we've
invested in previously and developed
over a number of years so we also kill
include those and again we'll see some
statistics at the end where we've
actually done that and we can solve sure
where the benefit of using the platform
so you know we've talked about the back
end you know as I say lots of components
from a visualizations perspective we've
utilized data studio to do the the what
we would cluster the standard dashboard
capability so again from a maintenance
planners perspective that is where we
are surfacing the consolidated
information so that's where the person
is and making those decisions to support
the the future I guess the maintenance
effort is required and again Google
glass that's where we're doing the the
guided investigation and again all the
components interacting with the GCP
platform taking data in giving data back
after some of the investigations have
happened I guess these are some of the
differentiators and we can call out from
GCP obviously from our perspective and
to end capability so we can obviously
collect the data process it analyze it
and then obviously do the
recommendations off the back of it
that's obviously very important I think
as as we mature within the area of
predictive maintenance having the
ability and I think probably some of the
announcements are correct from Google
this week you know they're continuously
investing in this area of machine
learning as well as what hate actually
doing so we can bring our enhance
capabilities and use obviously Google's
enhanced capabilities to progress that
as we go through
security is a big thing I think you know
Google is best-in-class from a security
perspective a lot at the time when we
you know you could figure in the
platform it's just there it just does
these things you don't have to worry
about it and there's lots of you know
out the box capability that we get with
the platform and again obviously we've
talked about different clients require
different needs speed performance the
scalability is obviously very important
for when we do a lot of the work around
the algorithms again I think we've
probably touched on this this previously
but you know my background is bi and it
used to be very humid you would go and
gather some requirements from it from an
end user you would write you know you'd
write write a document you would then go
away and build it and I think in this
day and age you've got more parties
involved with the whole process data
engineering is very key you know death
is no good if it's not meaningful clean
so there's lots of interaction with data
engineers and the data scientists but
obviously the important people on there
is the business operations people the
subject matter experts who understand
how these lovely objects work and they
need to provide that input and guidance
and again I think that's we found that
it's very critical in key to making sure
that anything your developers get gives
you the the right outcomes so why
attaching Google I think we've touched
upon it previously attached has got
heritage within the industry space and I
think probably is a single tagline it
would it would probably you know we were
using Google as a platform to bring our
I guess industrial expertise to the
market you know we we've got some we can
see the power in the benefit of using
GCP when we develop developing out of
these solutions so yeah that's a very
brief overview of the of the technology
I think as I said we're now going to
just go through the actual the
demonstration of the application thanks
Andy
now I'm assuming all of you have already
come past the booth and seen the demo so
this
be the second time you've seen it yeah
I'm sure I'm sure that's already
happened so just to give you an overview
of what we've done with our clients so
obviously our client doesn't just have
Lego vehicles Lego isn't the enabler for
AR to be a success and driving site it's
just an abler for us to demonstrate some
of the pieces we need to but essentially
our client was having is having a lot of
work that needs to be done from a
maintenance perspective around to
specific use cases so eith AC so air
conditioning HVAC in the states and also
their break elements that's where they
spending a lot of their time in terms of
maintaining their fleet of vehicles and
these fiscally uh vehicles is dispersed
across a large geographic region and
within their organization they have a
number of mobile workforce users but
they also leverage a contractor pool of
resources when they need to so we
started to think end to end about how we
can provide a solution to help them both
understand where to focus their
attentions and when to create the right
interventions before assets failed but
also how they could get the contractor
resources the right information when
they needed it visually as well because
the last thing you want as a worker is
lots of paper
the key thing around all of this as well
is from a data kind of management
perspective our client has access to the
data that comes off the vehicle so in
the Europe there's an obd to terminal
that sits inside a vehicle that streams
back lots of information about that
vehicle now
a lot of that is just noise right you
get lots of information but you need to
figure out how that is useful for you so
I'll just quickly touch on one of the
use cases we'll talk you through today
around air conditioning so our client
was noticing they have a lot of issues
in terms of client feedback for the
vehicles that they're borrowing around
a/c performance issues compared to a
some of the other issues some of the
other maintenance elements and a lot of
their maintenance work was around
repairing or servicing these a/c units
across their vehicles as and each
vehicle obviously slightly different
unit slightly different maintenance shed
your pattern that they have to follow so
we worked with our client to understand
what data points would be useful to pull
back from the vehicle around the AC
usage so looking at the time it took to
get from start temperature to the
desired temperature is a great starting
point in terms of both cooling and
heating but then we looked at failure
information we could gather from that
client to their maintenance records also
the external data sources that are
required to support their AC use case so
how do we bring in external temperature
information how do we at least test the
value of putting additional sensors
within their fleet vehicle so that they
can have a robust data set to be able to
get to a fault prediction perspective
what our client also noticed and and has
from an SME experience perspective is an
understanding that if you get to these
eight air conditioning issues in time
you can you can actually remedy them
before they turn into total failure so
for example if an asset has degrading
performance from an AC perspective and
our model is flagging that and we know
that that asset was serviced let's say
within the last six months it really
shouldn't be having any performance
issues that is probably an asset we want
to prioritize getting to to work on
because those issues within an AC unit
are usually down to pressure eroding out
the system coolant leak those types of
pieces and they're able to identify
based on what we've created those
elements in those areas where you could
get to it and repair the hose or and
improve whatever issue there is with it
so the whole unit doesn't fail so we'll
take you through that use case we have
two focuses from this perspectives their
data dashboards which Andy will talk you
through shortly where we're surfacing
all that information and we'll talk you
through that and we also have the
guarded AR inspection piece for that
mobile workforce as well Andy thank you
so just looking I guess from a dashboard
perspective this is very we play class
more the bread-and-butter bi type stuff
with them means to you know surface the
information and we need to take action
upon so again from a dashboard
perspective what we're doing here is
we're effectively summarizing the events
that have happened
now those events may be that the system
itself is generated or actually in this
case is where we've executed the models
and it's come up with these
recommendations of the things that need
to be actioned straight away so again
this is but this is more from I guess
work from Earth maintenance planning
perspective as opposed to the individual
again we can obviously drill into the
detail of that we can go and see the
specifics of where this thing is failed
so in this case air conditioning and
again based on so these conditions cause
obviously things that we this is the
score that we generate again that's
based on the the input factors for the
different components and models that
we're predicting against so again just a
visual representation of the information
that we're then ultimately going to go
and do some inspection against and
that's how we're other beautiful car we
sort of said that we've we've talked
about HVAC in and braking but as part of
the the data set that we actually had
the data scientists were actually
started to I guess evolved that if you
like and started to look at things
around drivers behavior because that's
obviously a key aspect into potential
degradation especially things our own
brakes where you have a drive who's
continuously braking and driving I guess
not to the optimum again something it's
very useful within the whole the fleet
for the industry's perspective is it's
also used on the trains it's similar
sorts of things where you want to try
and optimize that and again we've built
out some capability and again these
dashboards here are just showing the I
guess the aggregated views and some of
the the key metrics that people want to
capture
when your stockin starting to look at
driving behavior and again we can drill
into that detail skip through these but
again it again it's an education thing
so we saw we can obviously use that from
a where we have to go in actually
inspects and service the vehicle but we
can also do use these things from an
education perspective because obviously
it's the same driver it's causing the
similar sorts of problems and we can
obviously guess take corrective action
and which ultimately will obviously
improve that the vehicles he's driving
or she's driving and just to build on
that as well so our clients now looking
at the data we're bringing back from a
breaks perspective and drivers core
perspective to say well that's good for
maintenance but how can we start to
surface some of that information to that
end user that driver to let them know
that they're not driving optimally
they're accelerating harshly or braking
harshly not as a way of telling them off
but as a way of helping them understand
their performance we carry health
monitoring applications and it's just
about seeing what you're doing because
you may be let's say naive to the fact
that you're not driving efficiently
cool thanks sorry okay okay perfect so
this is the part where you actually see
the Lego Porsche is not just here to
look nice so essentially in this
scenario we've created an application
for our clients mobile workforce client
wants that mobile workforce made up of
contractors to be able to execute the
right activities from a maintenance
perspective there's two or three things
we're doing here and this is all about
the inspection workflow within this one
I'll talk the examples through as we've
got the video playing in the background
but essentially within the maintenance
world you would be surprised but there
are a large number of times where
somebody goes out to work on a vehicle
or an asset regardless of if it's a
fleet asset or any other asset and they
work on the wrong vehicle I come from a
background in rail slightly where that
was happening everybody feels like they
know where something is you get the
information from the data base and it
tells you it's in that location it's a
fixed asset you've been there a million
times you get there you see the
checklist you know what you need to do
you do it your market is done you don't
realize there was actually an identical
unit right next to any worked on the
wrong one so we use AR for our visual
identification through Google to help we
use or understand that asset now with
vehicles it's easy because we have
license plates we have registration
plates for those vehicles and with our
client they have three different types
of vehicles so we've trained it against
those three vehicle types but also the
license plate as well to remove that
chance of error for the demo purposes
you'll see today we've retrained the
model and we've done made some of that
data for unsanitized it so you can
actually see the AR image recognition
against the the lego unit itself the
other thing we do using the application
is we help the user understand where to
focus their attention for this
inspection so for example I may be a add
an AC inspection engineer however I may
have not worked on all the cars that
have ever existed in the world so it's
about surfacing the information for that
vehicle and it's all about us then
training the models to recognize our
clients vehicles and their assets so
scalable outside of just vehicles and
and fleet assets but immensely powerful
to helping people understand what they
need to do so in this scenario we're
essentially the p-side Walter out the
model was highlighted an AC efficiency
issue this could be due to gas
regulation within the system or leak
somewhere the AC unit was serviced quite
recently so it's actually something that
we're looking for our client to target
and get them out to complete that
inspection and we will go ahead and
complete an expression against that unit
so this is where we're hoping the magic
works and the video will play I will
probably pause it from time to time just
to recap them some of the things that
we're doing this is the same overview of
the use case and scenario that we're
working on but essentially
user is able to see the job queue the
work that they need to go and do and
obviously they get a lot of information
through from our model so whatever we
hold in the model will surface the right
information to them about what they need
to do where the asset is
and then we'll keep it playing we
essentially help them navigate to get to
wherever they need to do the work on so
for example using Google Maps to get
them to their location for simple
purposes we've simulated that for this
part we get to the asset and they need
to identify the asset so piece are
talked around earlier around working on
the wrong asset is extremely powerful we
need to make sure that we fix things
right first time on the right asset to
play this is where you'll see the AR
element come in so the a of recognition
element the user hovers the mobile or
glass device across the asset and data
is pulled back from our database to show
the pertinent bits of information that
we want to surface for that use case and
for that user
for this demo purposes we've pulled back
the mileage we pull back the air
condition score and the focus area as
well now as we click play the app also
provides information to important for
that user so that user understands what
it is they need to do so from an AC
inspection perspective there's usually
three things you go look at the
condenser the pressure that's within the
system but also check the fixtures and
fittings around the hose is there any
leakage happening in that space so
essentially the users given basic
information and then they're guided
through this so if we click play start
inspection they'll be able to that we've
told obviously where they need to focus
their attention they'll scan that asset
so this is using the camera to pull back
visual information check against our
model and then it pulls back the
information around what it is they need
to do so at this point we've called out
the three inspection areas now for
different vehicles different cars you'll
have different areas to have the hose or
have the condensing unit and this allows
them to click in and see what it is they
need to work on and the steps they need
to carry out as well so it's removing
the end of job checklist activities and
it's focusing that user on what they
need to be doing when they need to be
doing it this can get as complex as you
want it to be dependent on every cause
it just they're handy complex as you
want it to be depending on what asset
you're working on so it's really
powerful
and then obviously the information
having a press PLAY sorry it's pulled
through and that passes through to the
database so that we can have positive
feedback around what was completed
whether there was actually a fault and
it's reinforcement with reading codes so
our model can learn as we go so that's
the demo from the AR perspective and
this is where we're hoping that it works
and we can go next
again the value of why we're doing this
so the value of why we're doing this for
our client is to help them reduce the
maintenance burden and improve
efficiency from a maintenance
perspective so go and maintain those
assets before they fail so you don't
have to spend more time and result and
and effort when those assets are out of
commission later on down the line
improve the uptime for those assets so
if we can get to a vehicle and do a
small repair as opposed to having to a
large replacement it's been available to
be used by other parties and reducing
that capital costs so you do not want to
be going out and repairing a/c units as
frequently as you as you currently do
you want to be able to maintain those
units to a higher level of efficiency so
that they last a lot longer as well
perfect so key takeaways I know you're
all probably wondering so what and how
much all of this would factor in from a
data processing perspective so this is
just I guess an example of I guess why
the platform is really useful it's part
of one of the air conditioning
investigations we did some analysis and
we try to extend the dataset that we had
to simulate over I think 12 months worth
of information so you can see there were
those big numbers you know if we were to
try and do this I guess on premise we
probably struggle so this was a job that
we executed they obviously spun up as
you can see quite a large volume of
compute took about 22 minutes to run and
it only cost $12 so you know when we
give this of ability to our data science
team that they're very happy because
historically they're they're very I
guess mindful of spending lots of money
because they know how much
people were cast but when they were
actually amazed when the they saw the
results of actually how much these
things cost perfect and in terms of the
key takeaways from a let's say learning
experience with our client so fleet
optimization is a continual effort so
it's about understanding what you want
to do where you want to do in what you
want to try and improve from a use case
perspective so ACN breaks with the start
and our clients now learning all the
other things that they might want to do
based on the data we've been able to
pull up and surface for them data isn't
enough so the key point is as much data
as you can bring back isn't enough you
need to combine that data with
contextual information but also with
that subject matter expertise and the
ability to add new sensors and bring in
additional data points that you didn't
originally capture because it can
benefit what you're trying to prove so
for example with the use case around
brakes we brought in the additional data
around driver behavior because it's very
likely someone's driving badly brakes
are going to be impacted it's not this
sole factor for why that scores
calculated but it's a combination factor
then we bring in things like terrain
weather do those have an effect on how
people are using the vehicle from a
brakes perspective and the other key
takeaway from this is the speed and
scale that you can move out from
Google's perspective so you have all of
the access from edge data capture to
authentification of new devices using
IOT core to the use of ml and containers
to do the analysis against that data set
but also robust and powerful
visualization tools to help provide the
information for that end user to help
them complete their job so for example
when we were talking about the guided a
our investigation application we tried
it in two ways we tried it initially
with just a mobile application for a
user and when we tried it with the AR
piece and side by side and the client
was noticed also that the people who are
using the a our application will pay
more attention to the work they were
doing now maybe that's because it's new
novel technology but maybe it's that
little nudge that you need to
in the work that you're doing it's so
easy to say well I've done this form a
million times I know what I'm doing if
you're having to use the camera and
those elements it focus your mind on the
asset that you're working on as well the
other part here is all about technology
is important but if technology plus the
business context that helps you deliver
success and deliver insight your people
are your strongest asset this whole
process is all dependent on using AI
advanced analytics through a change
journey with your client understanding
what value you're looking to it unlock
understanding the focus areas that
you're looking to prove value in and
demonstrating that value to bring other
people into the fold and keeping those
individuals involve throughout that
process either through visualization
tools so soft prototypes that you can
work with them to help the business
understand what is coming and adjust
what is going to be delivered in an
agile way so that what they end up
receiving is actually beneficial to what
they're doing perfect
I think we've elapsed towards our time
and I think we have about five minutes
left for questions if any of you are
interested in understanding a bit more
about this by all means do you take a
picture and scan that QR code or also
have a look on the Hitachi Google
website and you'll be able to access our
information from the applications that
you saw as well and thank you very much
for coming along today thank you
[Music]